je me présenterai pas
pour être présidente de la république
voyez je pense idée je considère qu'avec
le pouvoir d'achat la sécurité est un
des éléments absolument essentiel et une
demande parfaitement légitime d'ailleurs
des français là la situation du pays
est vraiment très mauvaise
j'essaye de ne pas utiliser des
adjectifs
trop
catastrophiste et pourtant on pourrait
parce que on est confronté à une vraie
barbarie on est confronté à un vrai
ensauvagement on est confronté a
partout où je vais moi partout y compris
dans la danse dans la pub la campagne la
plus profonde partout j'ai des gens qui
me dit on n'en peut plus
on est cerné par l'insécurité cerner
dans les villes cerner dans les
campagnes cerner dans les transports
cette situation est vraiment très
inquiétante et il faut y apporter des
réponses et des réponses très ferme
les faits se déroulent absolument
partout maintenant on siphonne les
les comment dire les voitures pour voler
les sens on pile chantier ont puis les
exploitations agricoles on vole les les
bêtes sur pied d'ailleurs même parfois
les récoltes les l'engrais maintenant
c'est l'engrais qu'on wolf des quelque
chose à la moindre valeur dans notre
pays et bien les gens tremble que on
leur retire con
qu'on leur vole ou qu'on les brutalisent
et ça c'est insupportable
donc il faut faire deux choses
prioritairement d'abord il faut
régler le problème de l' immigration
anarchique et massive car je le dis très
clairement l'immigration anarchique et
massive contribuer à l'aggravation de
l'insécurité dans notre pays c'est la
raison pour laquelle je vais proposer un
référendum aux français nous aurons
sûrement l'occasion de parler tout à
l'heure qui vise à changer radicalement
la politique d'immigration pour que
enfin simplement les français décident
qui vient qui se maintient et qui doit
partir et qu'on fasse respecter la loi
notamment en renvoyant chez eux non
seulement les clandestins mais également
évidemment les délinquants et les
criminels et puis il faut
de la fermeté
bien sûr une fois de la prévention mais
il faut aussi de la fermeté et dans le
domaine de la justice les français ont
le sentiment que c'est devenu le laxisme
le plus total le laxisme par manque de
moyens bien souvent il faut le dire
il faut donc réarmer les policiers
moralement d'abord et je suis vous le
savez pour la présomption de légitime
défense je pense qu'il faut à nouveau
leur faire confiance ils ont beaucoup
souffert de du mépris de votre
gouvernement ils ont beaucoup souffert
de leur mise en cause permanente ils ont
beaucoup souffert des doutes que vous
avez exprimé à leur égard et donc il
faut les réarmer moralement il faut
d'abord les haies mais après tout
pourquoi pas aussi les aimer leur faire
confiance leur rappeler rappeler à
l'ensemble des français que c'est grâce
à eux que on peut vivre en sécurité et
puis il faut être beaucoup plus dur sur
les peines il faut la certitude de la
peine il faut arrêter avec les
aménagements de peine aujourd'hui grâce
à monsieur dupont moretti et madame
taubira avant lui avant un an de prison
ferme avant un an et bien vous
avez des peines aménagées bon excusez
moi mais les aménagements de peine moi
j'ai été avocat c'est considéré par les
délinquants comme l'impunité totale
voilà si la peine c'est porter un
bracelet allée au commissariat pour
pointer etc c'est comme si on ne faisait
rien donc moi je crois qu'il faut
revenir à la certitude de la peine je
sais mieux de mettre une petite peine de
cinq jours ou de quinze jours qu'on
effectue plutôt qu'une peine d'un mois
d'un an qu'on effectue pas voilà ce que
je pense et d'ailleurs les pays-bas me
donne raison car ils font cela et c'est
très efficace je pense qu'il faut à tout
prix que l'on s'attaque aux atteintes à
l'intégrité physique on ne peut plus
accepter dans notre pays que points oui
ou pour un non on vous blesse ou vous
violente on vous sautent sur la tête où
on cherche à vous assassinez ça n'est
plus possible et c'est pour ça que de la
manière la plus claire qui soit je veux
que l'on stoppe les les aménagements de
peine pour toutes les peines de plus de
six mois ferme quand il s'agit
d'intégrité fadoq mais tout ça n'est
possible et j'en termine très brune
peut-être chose à dire bien sûr sur ce
sujet mais tout ça n'est possible que si
évidemment on construit des places de
prison car il est évident que beaucoup
de magistrats ne peuvent pas
décréter une peine dont ils savent
pertinemment qu'elle ne sera pas
appliquée et ça c'est quelque chose
encore une fois de très nocifs donc il
faut femmes construire des peines de des
places de prison et notamment en
l'espèce 25000 ils sont absolument
nécessaires à bien par une valve est
presque 5 minutes d'avancé sur emmanuel
macron vous pose la même question
emmanuel macron cas marine le pen en
2027 vous engagez vous si vous êtes
réélu à ce qu'il y ait moins de violence
moins de délinquance moins de
criminalité dans ce pays
oui vous noterez quand même que c'est
assez difficile de répondre à votre
question telle qu'elle est formulée et
pour madame le pen comme pour moi c'est
évident que je m'y engage et parce que
j'en ai à cacher les moyens pendant son
nom et quels moyens allez vous déployez
pour ce faire j'y viens rassurez vous
d'abord parce qu'on s'en est donné les
moyens et
nous débattons aujourd'hui moi j'ai
aussi en mémoire ce qui s'est passé à 5
ans le au moment où nous débattions dans
un autre format c'était avant le premier
tour et policiers tombés veillez gêné
période et penser à nos policiers c'est
d'y penser chaque jour et c'est pas les
abandonner des cas un coup de grisou
madame le pen comme vous l'avez fait
quelques jours en parement des policiers
de monsieur darmanin quand il y avait un
problème dans un de vos événements savez
ça suppose parce que j'ai le sens du
commandement en effet
j'avais laissé leur ferai pas croire
sage mois durant ce quinquennat j'ai
tenu mes engagements
dix mille postes de policiers et
gendarmes ont été créés pourquoi parce
qu'on fait pas la sécurité avec des mots
avec des ventes ont serré avec des
postures on le fait avec des moyens et
donc on a créé dix mille postes de
policiers et de gendarmes ils sont
maintenant sur le terrain des sorties
d'école se sont achevées il ya quelques
mois et à côté de ça on a augmenté les
moyens de la justice
de 30% deux dernières années fameux 9000
magistrats que vous proposiez la
dernière fois nous y sommes donc nos
moyens sont là ce qui fait qu'il ya
d'ailleurs des résultats puisque la
délinquance sur les biens en particulier
a fortement diminué et les chiffres sont
aussi là qui le fruit de l'implication
de nos policiers et nos gendarmes de
services de renseignement des résultats
aussi sur la lutte contre le terrorisme
et je veux saluer ce qu'a fait le
gouvernement ce qu'on fait l'ensemble
des services avec plus d'une trentaine
d'attentats déjoués et le fait que vous
n'en ayez pas du tout parlé montre pas
que ce sujet s'est éclipsée mais que
c'est un sujet sur lequel nous avons
fortement augmenter les moyens
l'organisation collective moi ya quatre
choses si je devais en les sortir si je
puis dire les isolés sur lesquels je
veux pouvoir agir fort de ceux de ce que
j'ai fait durant ces cinq années de ce
que nous avons bâti le premier ce sont
les féminicides si les chiffres des
violences aux personnes augmentent c'est
à plus de 80% les violences
intrafamiliales parce qu'il ya une fin
d'omerta je suis fier de ça j'avais
d'ailleurs évoqué cet élan est tout ça
n'est pas vrai du tout monsieur
par des de manière gratuite si à une
agression toutes les quarante quatre
noms mais la course les victimes
derrière ça mais bien sûr d antan de sa
faire donc je dis jamais non plus ni
quand tu parles on va parler des
féminicides quand je parle des
féminicides c'est ce sont des victimes
qui sont aussi louable que c'est un
sujet s'est jetée que 80 % à 80 % les
chiffres qu'ils y adhèrent ces
augmentations ce sont ces violences
intrafamiliales et c'est féminicide ça
n'enlève pas les autres madame le pen
toutes ces vies sont importantes et tout
ce que subissent nos compatriotes est
important mais me relativiser parce que
je suis en train de leur relative à jour
merci de me laisser pesant que les
résultats sont pas très bon et donc non
mais on n'a pas ce que la parole s'est
libérée parce qu'on a formé des
policiers des gendarmes qui avant ne
prenez pas et moi je ferais pas d'une
politique qui consiste à cacher la
poussière sous le tapis parce que ce
qu'ils étaient avant de la main courante
maintenant il l'a prise de plainte parce
qu'on a formé investi parce que les
associations ont fait un travail
formidable avec nous parce qu'on a mis
en place des numéros 24 heures sur 24
parce qu'on a justement commencé cette
faut aller au bout très fortement
avec notre police avec notre justice on
a mis en place les bracelets sont pas
encore tous donné il faut aller beaucoup
plus loin on a mis en place des mesures
pour isoler et éloigner les conjoints
violents donc ça pour moi c'est une
priorité la deuxième c'est dans le la
ruralité
grâce aux moyens que nous avons dégagé
et aussi aux réformes que nous avons
fait sur en particulier le temps de
travail et la loi d'orientation et de
programmation du ministère de
l'intérieur qui est prête
on pourra créer 200 brigade de
gendarmerie dans nos campagnes et face à
cette violence du quotidien ce retour de
l'insécurité ces brigades auront un rôle
de stabilisation lutte contre les
stupéfiants qui doit demeurer une
priorité qu'on a lancé renforcée depuis
2018 mais aussi sur les insécurités du
quotidien la troisième chose dont vous
n'avez pas du tout parlé mais qui va
être le
malgré tout on sait qu'il est déchargé
qui l'est déjà pour nos compatriotes
c'est le cyber parce que c'est beaucoup
des risques et de l'insécurité va être
les attaques cyber contre les hôpitaux
contre les services publics les
rançonneurs priver les terroristes les
agresseurs utilisent et utiliseront de
plus en plus ses moyens c'est pourquoi
je veux créer le cadre législatif pour
le faire mais aussi les moyens en
mettant en place 15 cents
cyberpatrouilleurs qui vont permettre
justement d'abord de répondre très vite
de protéger on sait le faire parce qu'on
a une agence nationale mais il faut
déployer les moyens c'est une vraie
révolution en terme de sécurité et puis
le dernier point c'est la justice
évidemment ça ne marche pas si ya pas d
effectivité de la peine moi je ne
partage pas vos points sur les très
courtes peines parce que je pense que
mettre un délinquant légers dans une
prison où il va fréquenter des
délinquantes plus lourd c'est une
absurdité je pense qu'il faut à ce
moment-là avoir justement des moyens
pour les mineurs on a fait une réforme
de l'ordonnancé qui permet de
l'injustice qui passent beaucoup plus
vite faut leur permettre d'avoir soit la
rétention dans un environnement
militaire ce qui est une de mes
propositions soient des travaux
d'intérêts généraux sous contrôle pour
en particulier ses plus petits
délinquants mais ils n'ont pas entre ces
deux jours ou trois jours je vous assure
quand on regarde les trajectoires c'est
très peu efficaces bien mais surtout
faut donner les moyens à la justice
d'agir de passer est donc au-delà des
30% qu'on a déjà fait de ses créations
de postes jeu au bout de ces états
généraux de la justice que nous avons
lancée qui permettront de réorganiser
beaucoup de choses de dégager du temps
pour nos magistrats nos personnels de
justice mais je veux d'ores et déjà créé
8500 personnels de justice magistrats
est fier personnel qui perdent
administratif qui vont permettre
d'alléger la charge de nos magistrats et
de répondre beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
vite parce que un des point sur les
situations du quotidien qui est
insupportable pour nos compatriotes
c'est quand il y avait un sentiment une
réalité d'impunité quand la décision de
justice n'est pas assez rapide on a
commencé à faire avec les délégués du
procureur sur le terrain avec cette
justice de proximité il faut qu'on aille
beaucoup plus vite et beaucoup plus
finir par se réinvestissent vous avez
développé l'un et l'autre véritablement
vos programmes vous me regardez marine
le pen isabella née votre position à ce
que je vous avais eu cinq minutes chacun
pour développer l'offre parce que c'est
l'ensemble qui veulent parler de
l'insécurité pas terminé je sais c'est
un peu court quand même hein on a une
question si vous voulez bien sur la
laïcité
puisque le temps comme six disciplines
et qu'il ya cinq ans madame le pen oui
c'est vrai ou témoin qu'ont vieillir je
le crois que s'effectuent je serai très
respectueux à votre égard vous ça ne se
voit pas moi j'ai peur que ça se voit
beaucoup madoff
[Musique]